Nobody should ever have to find out what a
human body smells like.
Especially as it's being eaten.
Sally clasped both hands over her face, trying
desperately to block out the smell and to
trap in her nervous breathing.
She couldn't bring herself to look.
Every bone in her body wanted to take off
running through the forest, back out onto
the interstate, to try and find some help.
But there was nothing she could do.
She could never outrun that... thing.
It was too fast, too savage.
Even if she could convince someone on the
highway to pull over and help her, they would
just tell her she was going crazy.
Maybe she was.
Then the smell of her husband's body drifted
over to her on the wind as the crunching sound
of inhuman jaws filled the air.
Panic set in.
Then silence.
She couldn't hear anything, not even a whisper
in the trees.
Had she done it?
Had she survived?
That's when a red sneaker stepped out from
behind the tree, and Sally stared into the
eyes of the blood-spattered hedgehog.
*
Now, Sally had never been a gamer growing
up.
Sure, she played a little bit of Mario Kart
and had a few Nintendogs back in the day,
but the word "gamer," just wasn't for her.
However, love conquers all, and when she found
the man of her dreams, she decided that it
would be worth at least giving some of his
hobbies a go.
They started off nice and easy, playing a
bit of Stardew Valley, Minecraft, and maybe
some Overcooked here and there.
But before long, the pair of them were sitting
down every day after work, headsets on and
controllers in hand, ready to dive into the
latest adventure.
Just recently, the couple had gotten into
retro games, going back and playing classics
like Battletoads and Streets of Rage.
The challenge was addictive.
So when her husband John came home with a
copy of an unmarked NES game, Sally was intrigued
to say the least.
John explained to her that he had found it
listed on eBay under a very suspicious account.
He had gone to pick up the game after work
that day, expecting to be greeted by the smiling
face of the seller.
Instead, he had found a blank gray cartridge
and a very brief manual wrapped together with
an elastic band on a street corner.
The seller had listed it for virtually nothing,
and based on the description, seemed very
eager to get rid of the game for some reason.
So eager that he must not have wanted to stick
around to even hand it over.
Sally, already bored with this backstory,
snatched the manual up and read the title
of the game: "Professor Gould's Terrifying
Horror Challenge.”
There was no artwork, no branding, no publisher,
no stickers—nothing to differentiate this
game from being just a blank cartridge.
As far as Sally knew, it could have even been
a virus, some kind of malware game designed
to brick their NES.
But the words "horror" and "challenge" from
the title sold her.
She blew on the pins in the cartridge and
slotted it into place in the NES.
A black screen appeared with nothing on it
but two options: single player or two player.
Sally uncoiled a second controller and handed
it to John with a grin.
"You ready?"
Sally hit two-player, and a new screen came
up: "Are the people holding the controllers
the people who want to play the game?
Yes or no."
Sally hit yes.
A shrill beep filled the room, high-pitched
and grating on their ears.
John immediately grabbed for the remote and
turned the volume down on the TV, but the
beep just kept going.
The screen was a bright red, filling the room
with an unnatural bloody light.
John tried to hit the off button on the remote,
but the TV stayed red, and the beeping sound
continued, filling their tiny apartment.
Getting up and rushing over to the TV, John
tried to unplug it, but it was no use.
The beeping noise and the red screen persisted.
He looked back at his wife in confusion, but
she was looking elsewhere entirely.
There was a rat in the corner of the room,
with mottled fur, bloated flesh, and cracked
teeth.
It stared right into Sally's eyes, salivating.
Without a moment's hesitation, she leaped
up onto the couch and screamed.
But instead of running away, the rat slowly
crept forward, looking almost as if it was
smiling.
Then a second one appeared, crawling out from
behind the couch, followed by a third in the
doorway and a fourth beneath the TV.
Dozens of rats filled the room, swarming in
from all directions, climbing over one another
in a desperate attempt to get into the tiny
apartment, to get to Sally and John.
Sally clambered onto the couch with her laptop
and tried to kick away any of the rats clambering
up onto the furniture, but it was no use.
For every rat she kicked away, another one
appeared, until soon they were climbing their
way up John's jeans, their sharp little claws
digging into his flesh.
The rats tore at Sally's clothes, climbing
over one another desperately, heading towards
her mouth, trying to burrow their way in.
Hairy bodies filled her vision, and the stench
of disease made her gag.
Seizing an opportunity, a rat tried to clamber
through her open jaws; she felt its tiny paws
scrabbling at her tongue.
With tears filling her eyes, she took one
fleeting look at the man she loved and…
noticed something behind him.
A giant yellow bottle with the words "rat
poison" stamped into the side was sitting
precariously on top of their cabinet.
Half stumbling, half swimming, Sally pushed
her way through the throng of rats filling
their apartment and desperately grabbed the
bottle from on top of the cabinet.
Throwing the rats off her hands, she managed
to unscrew the lid, held the bottle high over
her head, and poured the thick, stinking liquid
all over the swarm of rats threatening to
engulf her.
The chorus of death filled the room, whether
it was the sound of the rats dying or their
bodies being evaporated by the poison, she
couldn't tell.
All she could do was push through to try and
find her husband and save him too.
And miraculously, within just a few seconds,
all of the rats had disappeared.
The room was empty, the same as it had always
been.
Even the big yellow bottle was gone from her
hand.
All she could do was stare at John as he stared
back at her, as the words "Level 1 complete"
appeared above their heads.
*
Welcome to SCP-1315, the most visceral, most
real, and most dangerous horror game you will
ever have the misfortune of playing.
It's not too late to back out at the menu
screen when you select how many players you
want; it's not even too late at the confirmation
screen.
But once you're in the game, there's no turning
back.
Either you beat the game, or you die trying.
Beating this game is no easy feat.
A copy of SCP-1315 has been in Foundation
containment since 1986, but in all of that
time, only one D-Class personnel has managed
to make it to Level 33.
It is not known how many levels there are,
but there is theoretically a final boss.
The reason why no one has been able to beat
it thus far is that with each level, the difficulty
of the game increases.
Relatively minor challenges in the first few
levels give way to extremely difficult, life-threatening
scenarios as the player progresses.
These levels broadly follow the same pattern
each time, but individual levels often contain
an element of randomness.
For example, Level 1 that Sally and John played
contained rats, but other tests have shown
subjects being swarmed by insects and spiders,
often coinciding with established phobias
that the subject has reported prior to the
experiment.
Two hours later, John and Sally were running
low on ammo.
With both couches pushed against the door
to the lounge, they both hunkered down behind
the TV, loading the remains of their shells
into the shotguns.
From out in the hallway, they could hear the
heavy footsteps of more animals rushing towards
them.
When the pounding on their door had first
started, they assumed it had been their neighbor
coming up to complain about their screaming
and running around in the previous levels.
John had been so deep in thought, trying to
work out what their cover story could be,
that when he opened the door and saw an adult
grizzly bear standing on its hind legs in
front of him, it had taken him almost too
long to react.
Sprinting back into the lounge, he found his
wife already loading rounds into the shotgun
that had suddenly appeared on the floor in
front of her.
With a grim expression on her face, she seemed
to have accepted their new reality—that
this was a game they were going to have to
fight their way through.
But with every bear that they shot as it tried
to push its way into their lounge, two more
had appeared just minutes later.
While they had been conservative with their
ammo, aiming for the heads and not taking
any risks, the pair was starting to run dangerously
low.
Was there an objective they were missing?
Were they supposed to have done something
to progress through the level?
Sally mashed a couple of buttons on the NES
controller, and then some text appeared on
the red screen: Objective: Survive.
Four bears appeared in the doorway and pushed
hard against the couch.
It slid out of the way, and they charged into
the room.
Sally and John desperately took down the first
two of them, but the dreaded click of the
triggers told them that they had nothing left.
Closing their eyes and bracing themselves
for the worst, the pounding of heavy paws
on their vinyl floor suddenly stopped.
The bears had disappeared.
Level 3 complete.
"Well, whatever's next can't be worse than
that, surely."
But it was.
They managed to hold out in their apartment
until level 9.
But then the windows behind their heads smashed
into a thousand shards as a black-booted SWAT
team swung into the room.
With barely any time to react, Sally and John
pushed their way out of the apartments and
braced themselves down to their car.
Slamming both doors closed, they took off,
racing towards the highway as the SWAT vehicles
pursued them.
Three hours later, the couple was running
low on gas.
Swerving their way along the interstate, their
eyes on the mirrors constantly, the pair was
pretty certain they'd managed to lose their
assailants.
Slowing their car to the speed limit, they
gently weaved their way through the traffic
towards the nearest gas station.
Trying their best not to look suspicious,
the two of them went inside, keen to stock
up on supplies.
Who knew how long this game would go on for?
They had already been active for hours and
were exhausted.
With the SWAT team hopefully long behind them
now, the adrenaline rush was starting to wear
off, and the reality of this situation was
starting to set in.
Hopefully, there were just ten levels, and
they only had one to go.
But with a sinking feeling in their chests,
each of them realized it was more likely to
be 100.
Definitely time to stock up on some supplies.
They were barely halfway around the gas station
when the words "Level 9 complete" flashed
in the sky above them.
Both John and Sally froze where they were
and stared at each other over the aisles.
A blue flash darted past them outside the
windows, then again going the other way.
Sally ran over to the counter and banged on
the glass.
"Lock the door, lock the door!"
But the teenager just looked at her in confusion.
And now it was Sally's turn to look around
and see her husband staring in horror.
On the other side of the glass, standing between
two gas pumps, was Sonic.exe.
With haunting red eyes, rows and rows of sharp
teeth, and blood dripping from his mouth,
the hedgehog stared intently.
Sally pointed out the window and turned to
the teenager, yelling, but the girl took a
step back, looking scared of her.
The girl couldn't see it.
She couldn't see Sonic.
For all these challenges, all the things they'd
been fighting... was it just in her head?
But there was no time to worry about that.
Sally jumped the counter and ran towards the
door to the back of the shop, hearing the
footsteps of her husband running after her.
She kicked open the fire exit but froze immediately.
Sonic.exe was standing there in front of her,
smiling.
It was toying with them.
They needed to run, to get out of here as
quickly as possible.
But how could they outrun Sonic?
"Hey, Sonic!"
John yelled from behind her.
"You hungry?"
He pushed Sally out of the way and threw a
handful of chili dogs out into the forest.
Hearing "hungry," Sonic spun around and chased
after his favorite food as quickly as possible.
That had only bought them a few moments of
time, but maybe that was all they'd get.
Sally and John ran back through the convenience
store and out the front.
They couldn’t run, but they could at least
try to hide.
A semi-truck had to slam on the brakes as
the pair of them ran across the interstate.
Without a choice of running anywhere else,
all they could do was dart into the woods
on the other side and hope that Sonic had
a bad sense of smell.
But as they ran through the woods, they could
hear an ominous voice echoing behind them.
"Got to go fast, got to go faster than that."
Sally found a tree and dived into cover just
at the right moment.
Her husband wasn't so lucky.
There was a flash of blue and a horrible crunching
sound before his body hit the ground.
Sonic.exe was on top of him in a heartbeat,
rows of sharp teeth gnashing.
Sally clasped both hands over her face, trying
desperately to block out the smell and trap
her nervous breathing.
She couldn't bring herself to look.
Every bone in her body wanted to take off
running through the forest, out onto the road
to try and find some help.
But there was nothing she could do.
She could never outrun that... thing.
It was too fast, too savage.
Even if she could convince someone on the
highway to pull over and help her, they would
just tell her she was going crazy.
Maybe she was.
Then the smell of her husband's body drifted
over to her on the wind as the crunching sound
of inhuman jaws filled her ears.
New tears flowed.
Then silence.
She couldn't hear anything, not even a whisper
in the trees.
Had she done it?
Had she survived?
Then a red sneaker stepped out from behind
the tree, and Sally stared into the eyes of
the blood-spattered, deranged Hedgehog.
Sally blinked, and it was gone.
Level 10 complete.
The open forest stretched out in front of
her.
Without a moment to catch her breath, Sally
took off running into the country on her own.
Whatever was coming next, she had to be ready
for it.
Now go check out “SCP-5094 - Miss J's Whiz
Kidz Schoolhouse” and “SCP-978 - Desire
Camera!”